hello and welcome to our second in our
series of audacity talks where we bring
so there was innovative people in
Silicon Valley into the audacity studio
and ask student questions today it's my
pleasure to have my dear friend
colleague co-conspirator and just
amazing role model Astro teller here in
the studio with whom I worked for many
years as many of you know Astro leads
googles and alphabets X division he is
captain of moonshots I think he defined
the word moonshot that since Obama has
adopted into his speech and he's one of
the most innovative and best people I
know on the planet
Astro welcome thanks for having me
Sebastian I really looking forward to
having this chat with you so what we
usually do is we have lots of questions
our students ask but before I move to
those I'd like to ask you two or three
questions myself sure and I can't not
start without your grandfather tell me
about your grandfather's and how this
relates to you today well sir to create
the context I'm often accused of having
two grandfathers with Nobel Prizes which
is sort of pseudo true but not actually
true Edward Teller my father's father
the so-called father of the hydrogen
bomb he was the father of the SDI the
Star Wars Defense Initiative for missile
defense and a number of other things did
work that probably could have merited
should have merited a Nobel Prize but
because Alfred Nobel invented TNT and
felt very guilty about that afterwards
and that's where his money came from he
was a committed pacifist by the time he
created the Nobel Committee and process
and medals so someone like Edward
winning the Nobel Prize really wouldn't
wasn't in the cards my fathers are my
mother's father though jihad double-o
won a Nobel Prize in Economics in 1983
and I'm not sure if this answers your
question but one of the things that I
learned from them was that it can be fun
to be in
hence about your work and you better
pick something to do in your work life
that you love doing because you're gonna
spend more than half of your waking
hours at work and and so you better love
it
so you have the dream job in Silicon
Valley I think you can invent crazy
things build teams around and try things
out what do you feel Monday mornings
when I go to work and how do you feel
fat abs when you stop working well you
of all people in Silicon Valley know
that while the job that I have is
wonderful it's a little bit more
complicated than you're just building
but look I skate to work or drive to
work in a great hurry on Monday mornings
I love going to work I'm really
committed and passionate about the
projects that we're working on things
that either currently at X like the
airborne wind turbines they're working
on or package delivery via UAVs we have
a range of robotics efforts that we are
doing we have done things in the past
like self-driving cars which you were
heavily involved in and things that are
no longer there but now the life
sciences group verily so all of those
things I am really passionate about but
the thing that gets me the most excited
is systematizing innovation it's the
process of nurturing each of these
things sometimes successfully sometimes
not successfully but trying to learn
from that and asking the question what
could we do so that we learn the next
time a little faster a little cheaper
how can we go through the process of
figuring out which is almost always the
case nope
that wasn't what we should be doing a
little bit more efficiently because
that's the rate limiting step of
innovation that's the thing that gets me
the most excited is culturally
pragmatically from a process perspective
how do you create a place that's
efficient at doing unusual things
I mean you are known to throw big
champagne parties event things fail
most other people like they wreck the
hairs they are really upset about it and
they're quiet about it if you're
shameful how do you establish
ah failure and that celebration of
failure well I'll give you a couple
different examples one of the ones is
when someone starts and they have some
skepticism about whether this is really
gonna function how they can be part of
this process I say hey Sebastian what do
you think should we be intellectually
honest or intellectually dishonest well
we're here and then of course you say
well I guess honestly of course say okay
well the project that you're working on
it either has an Achilles heel
something that dooms it to failure or it
doesn't would we like to find out about
that sooner or shall we put off
discovering that so much later sooner
okay good we've just agreed that we
should run at all the hardest parts of
the problem first so that if it has an
Achilles heel we find it out as soon as
possible we just agreed on that so let's
celebrate the act of doing that
independent of what the answer is great
scientists celebrate the process of
asking great questions and getting
well-formed answers they don't celebrate
success that's the wrong thing to
celebrate that doesn't move science
forward it's actually the big problem
with academia is that it
disproportionately celebrates success
and so if we're serious about winning
about achieving in the long term we have
to recognize that the process of winning
is 90% learning so I go through this
exercise to hey you you're just starting
at X mr. Sebastian the last project you
worked on when you were done if you lost
all of the the tools of all the software
but you can keep the people and
everything that was in your heads about
the project you had built and you had to
rebuild the thing once it was working
from scratch how long would it take you
as a percentage of your time five and
you say five and ten percent of your
time okay we need a name for the other
95 percent of the work for lack of a
better term let's call that learning so
the entire process of innovation is the
process of learning and how to make that
as efficient as possible and if that's
the case which I think we just agreed it
is then let's celebrate being awesome at
that 95
percent the last 5% is easy anyone can
do that it's things like that when they
go to the city and ask do you know mr.
teller there's some people in the world
who think of a grandfather I think by
now many more people think of it as to
tell our Eric teller we're your birth
name and he had Udacity in particular
people think about the 3rd teller the
youngest of all the tellers mr. Griffin
teller tell us the story well my son was
interested in learning how to program
how it is he he's 12 he turned to 12
recently and I had been pointing him at
a number of different platforms like
making mods for Minecraft a game maker
which is a now-defunct gaming system
that has a nice event based scripting
language that sort of allows you to get
much farther than you can with something
than some of the really basic logo like
systems but is easy to get started in I
pointed him at some of these things and
just none of them took the first thing
that really took was a code Academy and
he went through and he taught himself
JavaScript and Java and Python but code
Academy really teaches you the syntax of
the language and as a computer scientist
I was excited about him learning more
than just that but there really wasn't a
way to get him to learn worth that and I
just suggested that he try Udacity and
he said sure I'm not sure it worked for
me and I was relieved as an 11 year old
and I was shocked that after a month he
was meaningfully through his first nano
degree and he kept at it it took him
about 6 or 7 months to finish the first
nano degree he did which was the
undergraduates equivalent of a one-year
course does the introduction to computer
science nano degree and he's really
loved it he's taken some of the courses
since then I think is an interesting
sidenote he's puzzled but he hasn't gone
back to Udacity the thing he's obsessed
with right now is hacker rank and it's
not that he doesn't want to take more
courses but he wants richer program
challenges and hacker rank has a scoring
mechanism that's just feeding his desire
and X sort of Khan Academy like waited
to rack up these badges and I think I
was great and I mean yeah and I would I
would predict it over time
Udacity expands to allow for people to
get both in the same place there's
already these projects that you guys do
which were super motivating to my son
and I think as more and more rich
Project Work can happen and then
ultimately jobs can happen directly
through Udacity you guys are gonna you
are changing the world well I think we
have about six years left for your son
to find a job friends teased me that
says that he should either get a job or
his money I've told him since he's not
13 you guys may have a dodge on that I
happily I have anything he was money
like absolutely any day I'm gonna ask
you some of the questions our students
are asking and they have submitted them
through our website let's see there's a
question by javi and it's a following
question did you have the dream of
becoming a programmer when you were
young I'm not sure I would say I had the
dream of being a programmer I had a
trs-80 was my very first container yeah
then I had a vic-20 then I had a
Commodore 64 I think I graduated high
school rounds like when my Commodore 64
ran out of juice as they were then I had
an se 30 it was like the second
generation Macintosh se and serve all
through that process I spent a lot of
time programming I really enjoyed
programming but when I applied to
Stanford I actually applied declared
myself as being a political scientist
and because I taken too many AP courses
they wouldn't give me all the credit and
for reason I don't know why I think I
got a five on that I think I myself an
engineer well what they said is we're
not giving you your years worth of
credit for your
pure science ap mm-hmm even though I got
a five on it so I don't know why they
picked that one I think it was just
random but if you take a one quarter
course then we'll give you a full year's
worth of credit so I said okay I'll do
one more computer science and I took
this class which was called 106 C at the
time I don't think it exists at Stanford
anymore but was basically an
introduction to computer science it's
the fast track division right yeah yeah
exactly this is fast it was 106 BC yeah
exactly and I took it and I had a TA who
was out of his mind excited about
computer science and I thought that's
how I want to feel every day when I grow
up
and that's actually what caused me to
get on to the computer science track
little did I know this guy's name was
Nick parlante
Nick parlante was in his very first
quarter at the time this was 20 years
ago being a TA so I think he was just
super exciting
yeah Nick palindrome of course became a
famous lecture at Stanford and he's one
of the most exciting people in the field
yes but at the time I just thought I
guess everyone feels like this doing
computer scientist I want to feel like
that I'll do computer science it's
amazing how much the vibe that yes in
fact you became a TA at some point it's
time for me it's a story about teeing
for someone who wasn't quite there yes I
mean that was much later and so actually
right after that I applied to become a
section leader a TA for the
undergraduate courses at Stanford and so
I had to take a class called CS 198
which is called teaching computer
science and then IT aid for the
undergraduate classes for a number of
years while I was an undergraduate and
then in my senior year at Stanford I
actually applied for and got the job of
running CS 198 so it was kind of a nice
thing to go full circle and a lot of fun
people have gone through that process
Scott will Timnath who worked with me at
the time running CS one day me usually
you did it in pairs went on to invent
c-sharp at Microsoft and we actually
hired John Lilly to replace me and Scott
afterward
who then went on to run Mozilla for a
decade now a great lack and yes there
was a period one summer where I was
teeing for a dead person the SI TN
Network had these pre-recorded classes
and I guess he was a very popular
teacher and I was the TA and they just
didn't want it to slowed him down that
he had passed away recently they just
replayed his class on idea it's kind of
amazing because the sudden extend at
Udacity we're using material that's been
done by people who since departed from
Udacity luckily no one has yet passed
away my god it's coming full circle will
it go fast forward with the next
question student question by a person
named Musab and whatsapp is asking about
X and Ricky wants to know how do you
pick engineers that work at X do you
look for something in these engineers
yeah we look at for lots of things I
mean the first thing that we look for is
mental diversity if everyone is a
40-something white man with a beard
we're just not gonna think in enough
different ways to have interesting ideas
or to pick my ideas or your ideas apart
so we really look first for people who
think differently who come from
different backgrounds and this isn't
some surface-level excuse for having
ethnic diversity or gender diversity it
that happens as a natural side effect
what we really crave is this mental
diversity now there are certain things
that are triggers for us so if we're in
the middle of a conversation and you
worked at Parc for two decades and
you're a MEMS expert and in the middle
of me interviewing you you mention
offhandedly that you built a helicopter
in your garage I already know before the
interview is done we're gonna hire you
and this is a true story if someone who
worked at X for a number of years and
now works at at verily and if there was
just no question that someone who has
that deep technical knowledge but
fundamentally is a maker who has a deep
excitement about trying to make hard
interesting complex things that's the
kind of person who's gonna fit it X so
you're gonna watch the incoming email
stream for the next month sighs how many
by the way yes
these excuses wait but I'll give you
another one that I do I say to people
here sell me this oh you thirsty so
you've already passed the test what the
test isn't actually how well you sell it
but you'd be so I mean obviously you did
fantastic I think I so do an exit
something you did you did yes which it's
harder than selling me this but what's
important about that question is not how
well you sell but when you take an
engineer and you ask them to do
something which is not fair it's not a
normal engineering thing a lot of
engineers will go like this they're
angry they'll try not to show it but
they don't want to have to do something
which is not an engineering thing that
wasn't a fair question and some people
conversely embrace the weirdness of it
and I don't care whether they can sell
the glass to me what I care about is
whether in that split second I see the
flicker in their eyes that says I
embrace weirdness or I reject weirdness
the people who are gonna work well at X
embrace weirdness they don't reject it I
just want to point out we have never
talked about this before this was not
rehearse whenever you so nice was I hate
sitting water bottles okay I ask the
question how do you determine a moonshot
is feasible in the near future say the
next five to ten years this is going to
sound like a difficult answer I believe
not only can I not do that I don't
believe that there's any human being on
the planet who can do that reliably and
I think it's a failure mode for anyone
to believe that they can see so deeply
into technology and into the future that
they can reliably tell a moonshot from
an aqua job so what to do right so
that's the question of systematizing
innovation it's actually relatively easy
to get thousands of interesting ideas
onto the table metaphorically the
question then is how do we paw through
them efficiently so for some
you can say oh look this proposal
actually if you just turn it and think
about it a little bit you realize if
this were possible it actually is a
perpetual motion machine it violates the
second law of thermodynamics so we can
throw it out and you'd be surprised a
good five percent of the ideas can be
thrown out purely on the basis that they
break some law of physics then there are
a set of things where we can just do the
math and figure out that there's no
business behind it and not everything
has to be a business but things that
aren't a business are not likely to
scale and if you're they don't scale
then they're unlikely to really help the
world in a big way so we can discard
those things too so for some that you
know pass those tests we may have to
subject them to other things like have
smart people already tried this before
see if the answer is yes are we really
that much smarter than everybody else
that's not a good enough reason to think
it's gonna work you know so we throw out
a lot of those twenty people are already
working on this exact idea right now you
know what if we're serious about making
the world a better place and twenty
people are already trying we don't need
to be the twenty first group working on
the same thing let's let someone else
work on that one you know and so we go
through this process where we've built
skills over time different mechanisms
for discovering that something might not
be good eventually we get to the place
where there are some things left on the
table we might have to build some
prototypes we might have to start hiring
some people and only discover six months
from now that it's not a good idea this
is impressive here's a question from
Callum
this is embarrassing for me because he's
younger than me but he's he's 38 he's
been out of work for four years yet an
unsuspected tackler career before that
how would the millions of people like me
like Elm get a say in the future and
help to bring it about look I don't have
a penny there's a deep question it's a
very important question yeah I'd love to
hear your opinion well I have several
the first is you've never lived at a
better time
for getting a good answer to that over
time than right now because the world
has democratized
and the ability to add value in lots of
ways
that just wasn't true 20 years ago
number 2 Udacity is a very meaningful
central part of that answer that is it
is now possible without getting a lot of
permission or spending a lot of money to
go train yourself to be deeply skilled
and knowledgeable in areas that are
valuable Udacity is at the forefront of
doing that so that is not limited to
Udacity but certainly including Udacity
going and getting those skills making it
evident that you have those skills is a
very critical step to going and getting
people to take you seriously and letting
you be involved in these processes I
know that it's trite but believing in
yourself feeling that you have it the
world is no obligation to include you
and at the same time the world has no
reason to exclude you and if you believe
in yourself I don't see any reason why
you can't get more involved over time by
doing things like training yourself up
you know if I were starting over from
the beginning right now I would find the
most exciting place I could find and I
would offer to do anything there if I
were coming here to Udacity and you
didn't know me and this is where I
wanted to be I would say I'm gonna be
running this place in five years but you
have no reason to believe that let me
wash your dishes let me sweep your floor
I don't care what it is as long as
you're committed to paying attention and
giving me a little bit more room every
time I show that I have the capability
I'll start however low I need to so you
can build confidence that's what I would
do that she interesting the robot
Mondavi you will formed Napa Valley was
kicked out of his family he would know
penny on his hand in his 50s and the
billionaire fortunately but that was all
that and it's 50s and 60s and 70s
I think this vino age limit - I totally
agree I think the Asians and I had it's
not it's not physically I actually think
it's healthy to start over I encourage
people to start a new career at least
once a decade because at some point you
get a little stale in whatever career
you're in
part of the power of entrepreneurship is
the naivete that it comes from not
knowing all of the rules in your
industry but once you've been in that
industry and done really well for a
decade or more you are one of the
experts who is despite all of your
attempts received the blinders that come
from knowing that the quote unquote
right way to do so pick a feed there's
nothing the feet of expertise at least
once a decade here's a related question
by a student in Cameron knowing what you
know now with respect to the companies
you've co-founded and ran what would've
done differently even initially starting
up your career I had a wonderful time in
graduate school and I feel really
indebted to Carnegie Mellon to some of
my co graduate students I got to meet
you while I was there I certainly would
hate to miss that my thesis adviser
Manuela Filosa was absolutely
astonishingly good to me I learned a lot
there even despite all that I'm not sure
I would have done my PhD over again
because in retrospect while I learned
some important deep technical things
they were biased towards the academic
and especially since it I turned out not
to work academically but to work in
industry I think I could have learned a
lot of that more in a just-in-time kind
of way so personally I think I I would
at least consider if I could sort of go
back in time the idea of whether or not
I would have wanted to just start trying
to build businesses earlier it's
interesting because you did a PhD on
machine learning as I recall and then
moved straight into variable devices and
user interfaces kind of completely
different yeah I mean the the wearable
devices we built had introduced the idea
of sensor fusion to the to the field of
wearable devices so there was an aspect
of machine learning but it was a
relatively small piece of the overall
effort I mean as all entrepreneurs
discover in the end the actual technical
work is a very small piece of the total
work of making a business successful
it's for that reason you know I've
discovered I'm a culture engineer I'm
still an engineer I'm just a culture
engineer now much more than I make
technical person and so I would hate to
give up the technical background that I
have but I really value a lot of the
learning that I've had by being in the
real world a student named marnik is
asking me a question I am burning to ask
as well it's a very short question he
asks what technology are you most
excited about today well what
technologies give us a sample of crazy
things so some of them are obvious maybe
some non-obvious some of them aren't
even technologies they're groups of
technologies so an obvious one would be
deep learning
I think deep learning and machine
learning some of our generally aspects
of reinforcement learning are just now
coming into their own these are very
long-standing fields that have been kind
of clawing their way up the curve for
many decades now and the slope of that
curve just went from this to that and I
think people who are watching the field
are all we agree about that but anyone
who's not taking that part of the field
seriously is kind of missing the boat on
the other end of the spectrum
I think synthetic biology happens not to
be something that X is working on right
now but I predict that 20 30 years from
now people are programming cells and
life more generally in a way that looks
a lot more like engineering than it does
like science chemistry or biology right
now that engineer your favorite baby or
I was thinking more like an engineer
your favorite bacteria to do some new
useful things for you then engineer a
baby I think we have a ways to go - we
can engineer babies successfully but I
think the idea of bringing engineering
as a discipline to wetware specifically
to the synthetic biology platform that's
growing up but doesn't yet have a really
strong engineering sort of discipline
around it is something I think is gonna
change the world over the next 20 or 30
years let me run some technologies by
you and you just give me yes or no for
the next 20
yes no I don't have the right answer for
these things I just said that earlier
but okay how many I know they give you
minds of yet fusion I mean look if
fusion didn't work out we'd all be dead
you know it is what powers the designer
what sustainable fusion on earth too as
it as a source of energy of an unlimited
source of energy I so I know a little
bit about the plasma containment systems
these the DT reactions and the boron
proton reactions they use either magnets
or lasers to keep these like clouds at
just the right level so yes or no in
twenty it's 20% chance there's a chance
living twice as long I think that's got
a better than 20% chance but I'm worried
that we're gonna solve the physical
problem in extending the life of our
bodies without extending the life of our
minds cause right now
people's bodies typically not being
universally but typically outlive their
minds so we should be totally
uninterested in extending the life of
the body until we get good and at least
causing the life of the mind to keep
pace otherwise if you thought you could
live to be 150 but your brain was
basically gonna be off by the time you
were 90 are you really interested in
that do you think it 20 is he have brain
implants specifically brain in cancer
that do you read your brain and program
this stuff into your brain without
having to talk to people and read books
and so on 20 years from now yeah I think
it'll be more limited than people
imagine in a variety of ways it will be
at first a prosthetic for people who
have specific problems it will help
blind people to see again and that sort
of thing but yeah there will be brain
implants that are augmenting our brains
and at least some non-trivial ways
within 20 years they've EQ cancer no but
we will have taken can so over the last
30 or 40 years cancer has been taken
down several notches it's gone from a
quite medieval way of addressing cancer
too already sophisticated
staying and there are a lot of cancers
that are increasingly become chronic
conditions rather than a death sentence
and I think what we'll see over time is
that more and more cancers will move
from the death sentence category to the
chronic condition category with cars
flying yeah that's the case yeah so
clears yes effort so far whatever great
things would happen 20 other surprises
so here's one of the ones that isn't a
specific technology but it's just a
different way of thinking about things
that excites me a lot that you could
think of generally as robotics but I
would think of as intelligent technology
and I make that distinction for the
following reason historically people
have thought about making things strong
or safe or useful in very mechanical
ways so you make a building safe by
over-engineering it you make a car safe
by making it strong enough and crumbly
in the right way that even if it slams
into a brick wall the people inside will
be safe
looking at the car for example it's
starting to make sense to people to
think about weight instead of having it
survive the smash into the brick wall
what if we made it smart enough that it
just never hit the brick wall that
specific thing is about to change
everything in the world you can just
replace car with wind turbine for
example instead of saying what if we
make windmills cheaper and cheaper more
and more efficiently to say what if we
made the control systems for the wind
turbine harder but as a result took 95%
of the mass out of the problem which is
exactly what Makani one of the x
projects is doing and i predict that a
huge number of things in our world will
go through this transformation where we
will stop thinking in industrial terms
about how to make them cheap how to make
them safe how to make them efficient and
we'll start thinking about how embedding
intelligence into the thing and having
them be able to sense think compute and
actuates robots in the very general
sense of the word robots
will actually change whatever that thing
is whether it's a car or an airplane or
a building or wind turbine or you just
articulated beautifully the division of
artificial intelligence of making matter
smart it's a long debate today between
alphago who just won the world's best go
tournament all the way to self-driving
cars and X and many other projects share
with me your thoughts on is AI good or
bad I mean so you're asking the grandson
of the father is the hydrogen bomb so
this is sort of you know presses on a
complicated button for me but I feel
very deeply about this and artificial
intelligence like all technology is a
lever for the human mind it is a way to
amplify human agendas if the human
agendas are good it will go well if the
human agendas are bad it will go badly
and I don't think artificial
intelligence has shown any evidence of
being different than guns or hydrogen
bombs or electricity or the Internet in
having this fundamental characteristic
that they can be very positive or very
negative and I think it's a mistake to
try to label them as either so famous
people like Elon Musk and Steve Hawkins
have wanted a doomsday scenario they say
when AI become so smart without smarts
else is gonna enslave us and it's fun
with differences in biology then for
example electricity the internet or guns
have you joined the debate have you
thoughts but they thoughts about this I
mean so if you're interested my wife and
I at comic-con recently gave a talk
called
AI versus super babies which I did watch
but of us might not have what everything
what the highly recommended which was an
attempt to outline somewhat satirically
the fears of people that they have
around artificial intelligence and
around genetic engineering and the
debunk both of them what I would say is
is it logically possible that artificial
intelligence could end up being a net
negative
for Humanity it's possible it doesn't
make sense to argue that it's not
logically possible but I don't see any
evidence that it's at all likely to
happen especially when humanity has very
serious problems like global warming and
artificial intelligence stands a high
chance of making the world greener safer
improving medicine on a huge number of
fronts to make the world a better place
I think to slow that technology not only
makes sense on the surface it also won't
remotely slow the bad people working on
it it will only slow the good people
working on it you know the the fear that
robots will somehow enslave us because
they want everything for themselves
probably doesn't make sense for me
because that's a classic human thing
that we're doing which is projection I
think you will do what I would do
because I just have a limited
imagination but you're not me you're you
and if you're an artificially
intelligent system why would you want to
take over the world I mean frankly I
think we should be more worried that
artificial intelligence will grow up to
be smart enough that it will notice that
the things in this world who have it
really good are the dogs and the cats
they get to lie around all day do
nothing and take care of us if you were
artificial intelligence and you were
smoke so smart you could have anything
would you really want to do all the work
or would you basically pawn it off on us
and lie around the house all day I mean
why is no one worrying about that and
the answer is cuz it's not fun to worry
about that I get that but I think we
should be worried about things in a way
that's sort of intellectually
well-founded rather than sort of leaning
towards fear monger will be with you
with my last question I want to come
back to our students and many students
have very similar questions and I have
to admit as it's inspiring to listen to
you it's inspiring
do you think so many students want to be
like you and when a contribute want to
have the freedom to
do crazy things what can you give them
these are students around the world of
all ages is it in Indonesia in
Bangladesh in in China there may female
they're all the young what can they take
away today what they can do differently
what can you give them as a last piece
of advice to unleash their potential I I
have a very specific piece of advice let
me start by acknowledging I know that
this piece of advice will sound too many
people like jump off the cliff don't
worry you'll grow wings on the way down
you'll be flying before you hit bottom
it's not that way but I understand it
will sound that way but the answer is
live without fear if you make choices
based on all of the bad things that
could happen and spend your time
thinking about what you can lose you
won't get most of what you want and if
you embrace life with passion and
without fear it won't always go
perfectly not just for myself but I know
for you too and for many other people
who I know living without fear is a
fairly magical choice to make it would
be my recommendation I still love
talking to you I love you as a human
being and that's great a heavy a dude
acity it's great that you spend the time
with our students talking with them and
that's fine it's super inspiring thank
you for having you here Sebastian I'm a
huge fan of Udacity I really appreciate
what you guys are doing for the world
and I'm happy to be able to help well
that basically concludes our second
episode of Udacity talks we have on June
30th our third episode leslie founder of
poly